good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson center are you staying cheerful
we hope so
if you've been on the internet this week
you've probably seen the video we're
about to show you if you haven't seen it
there's really nothing we can do to
prepare you for the experience of seeing
it except to tell you two things about
it
first it's entirely genuine this is not
a hoax it's not a deep
fake it's not the work of some demented
comedic genius who set up a parody
account on twitter
no this video is real the second thing
to know about the video
is that it's from the cia and that's not
the culinary institute of america the
people who teach
baking and sushi preparation no it's not
it's the central intelligence agency the
guys who do water boarding and subvert
foreign elections
the cia is the most heavily armed and
supposedly
the most sophisticated intelligence
gathering operation
on the planet and yet somehow they
produce this
and then put it on social media
i am a cisgender millennial who's been
diagnosed with generalized anxiety
disorder
i am intersectional but my existence is
not a box checking exercise
i am a walking declaration a woman whose
inflection
does not rise at the end of her
sentences suggesting that a question has
been asked
i did not sneak into cia my employment
was not and is not
the result of a fluke or slipped through
the cracks i used to struggle with
imposter
syndrome but at 36 i refuse to
internalize
misguided patriarchal ideas of what a
woman can or should
be i am tired of feeling like i'm
supposed to apologize
for the space i occupy rather than
intoxicate people with my effort
my brilliance i am proud of me full stop
wait you're intersectional so am i what
year were you
just kidding she didn't say that she
said i'm a woman of color i'm a mom
i'm a cisgender millennial who's been
diagnosed with generalized anxiety
disorder
and then she told us hilariously this
spunky new cia lady
she told us that she is intersectional
but
laughter here and we're quoting my
existence is not a box checking exercise
well of course it isn't box checking
come on just a cisgender latina
millennial mom of color with a certified
emotional disability
not a hint of box checking there in fact
that sounds
like pure meritocracy if by meritocracy
you mean a system in which narcissism is
the highest achievement
at joe biden's cia the spies talk mostly
about themselves
you can just imagine what the job
interviews must be like tell us about
yourself and please
don't ever stop so you can change a
diaper with one hand and console a
crying toddler with the other
plus you're emotionally unstable perfect
you're just the person we've been
looking for to foil the next 911 plot
let's get you to the farm for some
weapons training
that's your cia at work now not everyone
has embraced these new hiring standards
the cia used to be out mission to
country wrote former cio
officer brian dean wright in an
observation that was widely shared by
many of his former colleagues
now it's about demanding and getting
accommodation to fix an emotional wound
or advance or personal agenda
america is less safe with this new cia
and dangerously more political
that's what brian dean wright wrote now
wright is a sincere and patriotic person
we know
he's a frequent guest on the show so we
do not contradict
brian dean wright lightly but is it
possible
that wright is taking this video too
literally could he be missing
the point of it what if the cia's latest
description of itself is not what it
appears to be
this is an intel agency after all these
are spooks
their world is a hall of mirrors so to
you and me and brian dean right
that video may come off as the babylon b
version of identity politics going wild
but maybe that's the point of it maybe
that's what they want you to think
maybe there's something more going on
here
now for months now the bidet
administration has told us that a group
called
white supremacists are america's most
dangerous enemy
white supremacists don't live in the
middle east their caliphate is right
here in america
in nebraska and western maryland and
believe it or not even the suburbs
outside minneapolis who saw that coming
how can you tell a white supremacist how
do you know when you're in the presence
of one it's simple
anyone who objects to being called a
racist without evidence
must be a white supremacist that's the
working definition of it beyond that no
one has defined the term
people in washington just repeat the
line again and again and again
in the apparent belief that frequent
repetition makes it scarier
and apparently it does former cia
director john brennan seems
genuinely alarmed no looking forward
that the members of the the biden team
who have
been nominated or have been appointed
are now moving
in laser-like fashion to try to uncover
as much they can about
what looks very similar to insurgency
movements that we've seen overseas
where they germinate in different parts
of the country and they gain strength
and it brings together an unholy
alliance frequently
of religious religious extremists
authoritarians fascists
bigots racists nativists
even libertarians that's quite a list
religious extremists authoritarians
fascists bigots
racist nativists even libertarians
yes says john brennan with a visible
quiver in his face
even libertarians even the guys at the
cato institution that's how deep this
white supremacist threat is
you may be surprised to hear that you
imagined in your naivete that
professional libertarians were merely
ridiculous
with their stupid little theories that
no one's ever tried because they're so
absurd they would evaporate like steam
if they ever made it beyond the walls of
whatever coke-funded think tank they
live in
though of course they never will but
it's much worse than that
the cato guys are dangerous john brennan
says just like their diabolical friends
at
aei they're the new al qaeda lock them
up throw them in prison with those
diabetic retirees from central florida
who've been rotting in solitary since
they dared to trespass at the capitol on
january 6th
lock them away from now on if they want
to communicate with roger stone they'll
help
have to use tap code if we need more
cells to hold them there is a budget for
that prison reform does not apply to
white supremacists
that's what john brennan has told us
that's what they're all telling us they
repeat it daily
the question is does anyone with an iq
over 80
actually believe a word of this does
anyone in power really
think something called white supremacy
is the single greatest threat america
faces no of course not no one thinks
that
susan rice knows it isn't true so does
barack obama
so do all of the other architects of
this particular lie they made it up in
the first place
so of course they know precisely how
false it really is
they may be liars but they're not
delusional in real life they understand
perfectly well what actually threatens
america they've seen it up close
it's the culture that produced them it's
the decadent rich people from their
class at harvard
it's the gender studies department at
cornell it's the cat cafes in austin and
asheville
it's the monday editorial meetings at
the atlantic magazine where david frum
is treated like an important
intellectual rather than some dopey
middle-aged canadian twitter celebrity
whose life goal is to force america into
yet another unwinnable pointless war
those are the people who actually detest
the country
they're the ones who are working through
the night to destroy it
they're the people who are committed to
and in the process of excusing violence
so if you wanted to save america these
are the people you'd be worried about
they make the iranian nuclear program
look like nothing
so maybe the cia actually does know this
maybe they really have figured it out
maybe the intersectional lady with the
emotional problems is in fact
a deep cover operative think about that
it makes sense actually
when defeating isis was the goal we
recruited arabic speakers
why wouldn't we now that our own
professional class
is obviously the real threat we need
people who can blend in
at mckinsey in the middle east and here
we need
agents who understand the enemy who
speak his language who understand his
customs
who can break bread with tribal leaders
in a yurt in the mountains or for that
matter in napa
or on the quad for a mission like that
we are going to need a brand new kind of
spy the old kind will not do
yeah good luck pal good luck on the
brown campus
yes those were cigarettes without
filters but not the right kind
that guy was smoking testosterone
enhancing tobacco
i think the enemy wouldn't notice that
he would have been arrested at the door
on a hormone violation game over cover
blown
they do to him what the soviets did to
gary powers get ready for a show
trial but this progressive new cia agent
by contrast would never be discovered
they wouldn't suspect her for a moment
because she's just like them
they're unhappy she's unhappy they've
got
diagnosed emotional disorders so does
she they can talk about themselves for
eight hours at a time
she can too talk about deep cover
this woman is a natural mole the kim
philby of wokeness
the bite administration appears to be
training a lot of spies like this they
know that this is a war that will not be
won in a day
existential struggles never are so
they're marshaling
all the forces of government from dhs to
the president's own
personal flag even the interior
department has a role to play
watch these ladies try out their social
justice disguises
my name is laura daniel davis and i
recognize
that i live and work within the
ancestral lands of the anacostians
in the anacostia and potomac river
watersheds
i acknowledge the place-based knowledge
of these peoples
and i'm grateful for their ancestral and
current stewardship of these lands
my pronouns are she her my pronouns are
she and her
and i recognize that i live and work
within the ancestral lands of the
cheyenne and you people
my name is amanda lefton my pronouns are
she
her and i am the director of the bureau
of ocean energy management
i recognize that i live and work within
the ancestral lands
of the hodenshone and mohican peoples
i want to give thanks to anacostians i
acknowledge the plant-based knowledge of
these people and i'm grateful for their
ancestral and current stewardship of
these lands my pronouns are she and her
now you listen to that from an employee
at the interior department and you think
to yourself
that can't be real and let's hope you're
right
let's hope it's a ruse journalist hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else